le préfet monsieur votre ville le maire
monsieur bedous le recteur monsieur
niveau le collaborateur direct du
professeur neil était aux côtés de ce
dernier qui était accompagné de sa femme
renault bleu honorer ce matin son homme
de science en présence de très
nombreuses personnalités et élus
parlementaires officiers mais aussi
simple grenoblois le premier discours
fut prononcée par l'adjoint de monsieur
neil au cng monsieur balligand qui
déclara notamment
je voudrais simplement vous dire ici que
vos large vue sur tous les problèmes
scientifiques les hautes fonctions que
vous exercez dans de nombreux conseils
scientifiques de france de l'otan et
d'autres organisations scientifiques
internationales font de vous un guide
très sûr pour nous tous
monsieur félicie collaborateur direct du
prix nobel parle au nom du cnrs et de la
faculté des sciences puis ce fut au tour
du recteur monsieur niveau hommes de
science et homme d'action
le professeur mais elle a pris une part
déterminante dans cette collaboration
efficace qui quoi qu'on dise est
essentielle pour le progrès scientifique
et technique et donc pour le
développement de l'économie du pays
si grenoble attire plus facilement que
d'autres métropoles des industries
nouvelles aujourd'hui et demain c'est en
partie grâce au succès de ses chercheurs
et aux effets d'entraînement réciproque
entre recherche scientifique et
développement de l'appareil productif
après un intermède musical le maire de
grenade sud et bedous pris la parole à
son tour il s'est trouvé que grenoble
vous a choisi ou plus exactement que
vous avez choisi grenoble 10 et trouvez
que votre destin a été lié à celui de la
ville il s'est trouvé que la population
de grenoble vous a permis de rassembler
autour de vous des que le batteur de
choix de développer des recherches et de
trouver dans votre environnement
un puma favorable pour développer dans
l'industrie des recherches et inventions
dévié mise au point dans vos
laboratoires consécration de la
cérémonie le maire devait remettre
professeur neil la médaille d'or de la
ville ainsi qu'une gerbe de roses à
madame neil le savant était visiblement
ému par tous ceux ci on devait le sentir
dans les remerciements qu'il prononça
ensuite rappelant les origines et
l'historique de l'installation de la
science à grenoble il devait déclarer
notamment ses réalisations été possible
que grâce aux conditions favorables que
j'ai rencontré des monts
arrivé ici depuis 1940
je suis heureux justement d'avoir
l'occasion de remercier tous ceux qui
ont permis cette cérémonie simple et
émouvante après les grandes
manifestations de stock comme une ville
entière a rendu hommage à l'un de ses
plus illustres europe